nightmare mode can be well just that an
absolute nightmare so while we have a
basic doom eternal tips video I put
together just a few nightmare difficulty
ones to help the doom Slayers out there
who want a little bit of an extra
challenge you are going to die a lot and
the further you get into the game the
more you're going to die to that and our
objective is to minimize the number of
times our doom Slayer takes a short trip
down the river Styx the saving throw
rune allows you an extra chance every
life letting you push on with one health
point slowing times with crawl and
giving you one more shot at survival buy
glory killing of blood punching your way
out of a sticky situation I can't tell
you how many times this has helped me
complete an arena or Slayer gate
mercifully preventing the dread of
seeing myself gypped by a revenant
rocket and forced back to a previous
checkpoint only to face the same horde
of demons again and again and if you
ever get confident or cocky enough you
can always swap the rune out for another
one later on two things are vital to
keep in mind while playing nightmare
mode how much health you have to play
with and your ammunition so that end you
need to make every shot count
and keep each demon ripe for ripping and
tearing so you can heal off of them in a
pinch after a few hours of playing it
was ground into me just how many shots
with a heavy cannon it took to take down
basic fodder enemies or how close I
needed to be to stagger an enemy a
shotgun rather than totally Jib them
after that I was counting each shot
anywhere from two to five so I could
ensure I was able to do glory kills the
most efficient amount of ammunition if
you get into this habit in the early
game it will serve you well into the
late game areas where it's imperative to
have a zombie saved up to tear apart
[Music]
I was challenged to play through the
game on nightmare mode at our HUDs the
video on that you can watch right now
but this method taught me how to make
the most of each exploit and mechanic to
increase my chances of survival while I
was using the weapon wheel menu so I had
some idea of how many rounds I had left
I realized that time around me would
slow I thought there would be some kind
of limit to this but it turns out I
could move and take advantage of the
slower pace of things to take in my
surroundings and plan my next move if
things got overwhelming I was able to
take a moment to regroup as I forced the
world around me to a crawl that way I
could take know of every enemy and
easily pick the right tool for the job
perfect or if you're being chased or
have one too many plasma shots being
sent away
there's plenty to find in the dark
corners of the levels of doom eternal
and while the game suggests taking a
trip off the beaten path it's really
imperative to do so on the higher
difficulties taking a detour between
battles can often pay off in big ways
especially as each upgrade point on
extra life and that's so much more while
playing through on nightmare making sure
you get all the prey to oaken's 1 ups
and boosts will help you keep on keeping
on through your uphill struggle take it
from me those tiny health boosts or
survival perks really can make the
difference between Slayer and slain
alright so this one is a real cheesy one
but dire times call for drastic measures
if you already stuck on one of the later
levels you can actually go back to one
of the previous missions pick up the
extra lives quit out and rinse and
repeat in fact in the second level there
is a one-up literally next to the start
of the level like I said it's cheesy
it's gross but the demons aren't going
to fight fair so why should you so those
are my tips for doom eternals nightmare
difficulty if you want more tips you can
check out the previous video we did that
covers the game in its entirety and we
have lots more doom eternal content
coming your way so make sure you
subscribe to GameSpot